freaking cosmic wonder i thought we'd
get at least
one day away from you this empire
magazine's not even gonna drop until
tomorrow there's
all these things releasing
this article is going to be like the
most insane thing it's going to be the
end game of articles it's talked about
so much tomorrow there better be like
the juiciest stuff in the world in there
without a hype around this
picture toby and anne magazine we got
this video today from warren spiderman
no way home new look and toby and andrew
confirmed by article question mark that
people fail to read and think is a
declarative statement let's see what's
going on here
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we have a brand new look at
spider-man no way home and awesome whoa
wow
just this morning not too long ago and
it is
a cool shot
for spider-man is coming out tomorrow
plus we've had a lot of spider-man no
way home plot leaks and if you've taken
a look at all of them
all of them that seem to be coming from
somewhat legitimate sources all seem to
have a common theme and that common
theme is a particular scene involving a
death and the empire magazine article
has actually been leaked ahead of time
which i'm not going to talk about until
tomorrow when it comes out because it
really
exclusive however there is one point
that i would like to mention in this
video first things first we have to talk
about this amazing photo that was just
released this photo may remind you of
spider-man 2.
robotic tentacles he's actually only
using two tentacles here one to wrap up
his body and the other two hold his head
now luckily spider is that third one
going though spider suit however i'm
pretty sure doc is going to tear that
apart now we actually know that
spider-man is going to have multiple
suits during this movie one of them is
going to be a magically enchanted suit
and perhaps one of the reasons that he
gets a new upgraded suit is that doc ock
tears his iron spider one apart which
means that doc ock and the other
villains could actually arrive pretty
early on in the movie the spell is
probably going to be done way early into
the first act if you're implying because
doc ock tears up his iron spider suit
and that's why he has to get a magic
suit to take on doc ock i know there's
other villains in here but if that is
the implication
do i really need to say if i like that
or not i'm not a big fan of that idea
yeah i want to set up a motif where
every time he meets stockholm he tears
off his life he's got to get a new
costume like we saw toby take on doc
with his
but he does have other villains to deal
with and perhaps i'm just reading too
much into uh the statements here but
yeah this shot is so much better than
the other shots
feels menacing and yeah immediately has
you going back to like spider-man 2 and
so watching that definitely like wow
that was that's a beautiful looking
image right there and you could still
turn it into a meme now this is a sick
shot but check out what is written down
in the right hand corner i believe this
is coming from director john watts it's
a quote that says spider-man no way home
isn't just a sequel it's a massive meta
multiverse outing in which peter parker
finds himself fighting iconic villains
from past lives as its creator tells us
this is nothing less lies
okay they got a clue right there
spiderman game gives me the chill butt
in the film but to me this kind of says
it i 100 agree with you
yes i agree as well it says past lives
right there all i can see is like one of
those charlie day like you know big
boards of how do we say it without
saying it let's use past lives let's use
alternate universes let's use classic
legacy any terminology we can use to say
it without saying it they're not even
trying at this point no it's gonna be
good there's gonna be like a whole like
hindu aspect to the movie spiderman's
gonna get reincarnated it's gonna be
crazy all we're itching for right now is
just 100 percent confirmation
oh we're itching for right we're just
right it's like you could see the
confirmation there and we are crawling
dehydrated towards that finish line
but it's just right there there's the
confirmation
they literally say it's a meta
multiverse outing in which peter finds
himself fighting iconic villains from
past lives how are you going to pull off
mentioning past lives if you don't
explore those past lives and obviously
our tom hollands peter parker does not
have past lives but the others do he's
literally talking about spider-man's
past lives tom holland does not have
past lives but
there is literally no other meaning to
peter parker's past lives than toby and
andrew the films that came before him
the past films to me this is pretty much
all the confirmation that i need now we
just wait on that second trailer and
hope that sony and marvel give us a
little tiny tease of the other two
spider-man but of course i would not
leave you without news about that
trailer this is it's tomorrow
night
twitter account with great power which
is a book that is about the story of
live action spider-man one of the
writers sean o'connell tweeted from
there talking about the trailer he said
a lot of people somehow missed my point
there's a high probability that you will
get a second morbius trailer before you
get that anticipated spider-man no way
home yes
[Laughter]
because even sean himself says there's a
high probability it is not confirmed
however the marketing has been so weird
and different for spider-man far from
home i would no way home and
i pointed this out to warren when we
were driving to the eternals
i have never heard a movie said
incorrectly so many times in people's
videos not you know exclusive to this
there are other people too who are doing
spider-man videos yeah
far for moments out of nowhere easy to
get mixed up also with the morbius thing
that would be a terrible idea i think to
release the trailer beforehand anytime
we are itching for a spider-man trailer
and then sony puts out something else
people just get upset yeah that's what
the comment boxes are filled up with and
this is coming out before morbius so
just don't do that because we don't make
people hate morbid people get mad at
morbidly
the other one is about what some plot
leaks are saying there is a major death
scene according to these and it's with
somebody that you are definitely not
going to want to see die however if this
is true i can kind of see what it's
going to be setting up for the future of
spider-man now of course these are not
confirmed to be true yet they are just
rumors but in case they are true i am
issuing a spoiler alert if this does
indeed come true it's a pretty big scene
so many reports and plot leaks posted on
reddit have some things in common and
one scene that they have in common is
aunt may dying in case this is true i
won't say much about the scene however i
will say that i could understand why
this would happen because rumor has it
that at the end of spider-man no way
home dr strange's spell finally works
and everybody and i mean everybody
forgets that peter is spider-man now
this may sound extreme but fans have
actually been complaining for a pretty
long time now that we haven't seen
spider-man on his own he's always had
help he's always had some type of
amazing number one
always
deus ex on may setting for some people
because we want to see peter on his own
taking on all of these challenges by
himself having to step up well if in the
next spider-man may is gone and nobody
knows who he is he is definitely going
to get that chance seems a bit extreme
but we'll have to wait and see maybe
they'll handle it well i know like a lot
of this is seeming inspired by one more
day or the follow-up what is that one
called
oh forget the title of it moment or
something like that one moment in time
or something
but i think though with aunt may because
she dies in the one more day comic
however that's not beloved comic and
also part of peter being on his own a
big integral ingredient to that when
he's trying to financially help out with
aunt mate too while he's trying to do
school was trying to be spider-man and
ant-man struggling with the bills and
he's trying to help her out as much as
possible i mean this is still hot young
at me even though marissa's homemade is
not like incredibly young let's face it
she is the youngest host
yeah he definitely would maybe it'll
work within the context of it but i
don't think this is what people were
getting at when talking about being on
his own it was more about the reliance
on suits tech mentors in the superhero
universe not so much about that damn man
may holding him back from being on
dystonia the distractions from the world
of spider-man of which aunt may is not
she's an integral part of the world of
spider-man yeah they didn't come out and
say hey toby mcguire and andrew garfield
are in this movie they do reference the
sam raimi universe and the web universe
stating that the villains come from this
universe and if the villains come from
this universe then we can imagine that
some heroes come from that universe as
well they're not variable article comes
out tomorrow and i'll be doing a full
coverage
in the meantime let me know what you
think about this brand new picture of
doc ock holding spider-man in the
comments down below and also let me know
what you think about this possible death
of aunt may leave your thoughts down
below don't forget to like this video
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
awesome yeah that was great man that was
exciting that was a favorite one we've
covered so far this week from you
absolutely just got four more videos to
cover from you this week and then we're
done
all right warren i'm gonna shoot you a
text right now but thank you guys
subscribe to the cosmic wonder he's
holding down the four with all these
spider-man vids subscribe to us keep a
lookout for anything marvel related that
we
you you okay outro is done